it probably won't surprise you to learn
that there has been a rash of violent
crime involving young people in
Washington DC recently of course there's
a lot of violent crime involving young
people in every major uh city in America
but in our nation's capital the problem
is especially pronounced for example
between 2017 and 2022 DC's homicide rate
Rose by
180% other crimes like carjacking have
risen almost as dramatically during that
time frame so what could possibly be
driving this epidemic that's a question
that some people in positions of
authority are finally starting to ask
themselves on a national level the
Democrat Party still hasn't noticed the
crime the Mayhem the murder plaguing our
cities but on the ground in these
communities even the most oblivious
political leaders have been forced to at
least admit that there is a problem but
what is the cause of the problem well a
recent report from uh some kind of
agency that makes reports about this
stuff claims to have the answer reading
from uh WTOP and DC quote music videos
and inflammatory social media posts have
been a driver of shootings in the
nation's capital in recent years
according to a report released this week
by the criminal Justice coordinating
Council an independent agency in DC that
identifies local public safety
challenges researchers spoke with Street
Outreach workers uh violence interrupts
and more than 70 police officers in DC
who were selected for their particular
knowledge and expertise of gun violence
among those who were interviewed there
was nearly unanimous agreement on the
primary driver of gun violence there's a
deadly mix of group crew gang members
making music videos taunting or
disrespecting their Rivals that are
posted on social media and those videos
spark or further inflame neighborhood
conflicts that escalate into shootings
according to the report while the music
videos were identified as the primary
issues other comments and pictures post
social media by group members also lead
to shooting additional uh leading causes
of shootings include drug sales drug use
robberies personal disputes such as
fighting over a young woman and the
increased availability of firearms the
report found the article then goes on to
mention that out of the nearly 1,000
shootings both homicides and non-fatal
shootings in DC in 2021 and 2022 almost
all of the victims and suspects were
black male and under the age of 35 which
is not breaking news to anyone who's
paid any kind of attention the violent
crime problem everywhere in the country
from coast to coast is driven in a
vastly disproportionate Way by young
black males now are music videos and
social media posts to blame that's one
Theory a reported from DC's Fox
affiliate offers some other ideas to
explain specifically why juveniles are
increasingly committing these crimes
watch tonight new insight into the crime
crisis involving young people in the
district there has been an alarming
increase in the number of teens involved
in shootings and homicides in DC but our
Katie Barlo reports there is much more
to this story she's live in northwest
for us tonight
Katie well Kenneth although there has
been an increase an extraordinary
increase in juvenile involvement in both
shootings and homicides juveniles still
constitute a small portion of overall
shootings in the district that's
according to a new report from the
criminal justice coordinating Council
but the report rep also notes that over
a quarter of suspects arrested for
non-fatal shootings are kids and that
number has gone up we think a lot of
things need to change we think for
example that we need to have greater
prosecution of juveniles um we have seen
our kids become more violent at younger
ages and have less
accountability DC's attorney general
Brian schwabb is responsible for
prosecuting juveniles Schwab's team
pushed back on the mayor today saying
they prosecute 85% of gun possession
cases involving a minor and 65% of
carjacking cases a spokesperson said
finger pointing and playing the blame
game will not improve Public Safety but
also points out that there needs to be a
focus on prevention before prosecution
becomes
necessary finger pointing and playing
the blame game won't help says the
Attorney General but actually of course
it will in fact the first step in
solving any problem is to figure out who
or what is to blame for it the blame
game is a critical part of the problem
solving process and usually you can
identify the parties to blame because
they're the ones saying we shouldn't
blame anyone you know it's like the
people that are out there say don't
let's not play the blame game well those
those are always the people to blame no
matter what the situation is it's
perhaps not a surprise that the blame
game is the least fun for the people who
are actually to blame for the problem
and in this case the Attorney General's
office defends themselves against the
charge that they aren't Prosecuting
criminal Minor by pointing out that they
do prosecute 85% of gun possession cases
and 65% % of carjackings now I don't
think I've ever seen someone so
thoroughly incriminate themselves in an
effort to exonerate themselves only 65%
of carjackings involving miners are
prosecuted that's not even the number of
convictions or jail sentences passed
down those are just prosecutions that's
to say nothing of the lenient sentences
and plea agreements that are often given
recall for example those two teenage
girls who carjacked an Uber Eats driver
in DC and killed them in the process and
they were prosecuted and uh and the
prosecution resulted in a sentence that
will have them back out on the street
when they turn 21 that sort of thing
happens a lot but even by the Attorney
General's own admission and remember
this is a statistic that he offered in
defense of
himself 35% of carjackings by miners
aren't prosecuted at
all 35% of carjackings it's not even
like just vehicle theft which is also
bad the actual car jacking where
someone's in the car and you drag them
out or point a gun at them and take the
car um
do you know what that number should be
like the number of carjackings that are
not prosecuted you know what percentage
of carjacking should should be
completely ignored by prosecutors um
0% anything above 0% is a scandal 35% is
a is a
farce there were almost a thousand
carjackings in DC last year which was
double the year before that if 35% of
juvenile carjackings aren't Pro
prosecuted that means dozens if not
hundreds of carjackers are intentionally
and knowingly left to roam the
streets and and that's a number that the
authorities in the nation's capital are
proud of they're saying see we're tough
on crime we only let a third of our
carjackers go without even a slap on the
wrist we're experiencing a lot of global
instability as we plunge into the new
year North Korea is testing missiles
Iran continues to increase its
aggression oh and by the way we have a
presidential election coming up in
November how do you protect your family
in the midst of all this chaos a great
place to to start is by protecting your
savings it's not too late to invest in
gold with Birch gold group today unlike
many other Investments gold can act as a
safe haven investment during turbulent
Times by providing a hedge against
inflation and economic uncertainty Birch
go will help you convert your existing
Ira or 401K into a tax sheltered Ira in
Gold it won't cost you a penny out of
pocket while diversification does not
eliminate risk entirely Birch gos
experts can help you manage and reduce
providing a more resilient foundation
for your financial well-being I urge you
to talk to to one of their trusted
experts today just text Walsh to 98 9898
and bir gold will send you a free info
kit on gold with an A+ rating with a
Better Business Bureau countless five
star reviews and thousands of happy
customers I encourage you to check out
Birch gold today they've been the
exclusive gold company of the daily wire
for the past seven years you could trust
them and uh I trust them as well text
Walsh 29898 98 to claim your free info
kit today that's Walsh 298
9898 secure your savings now so is this
the reason why so many kids in DC and
across the country are becoming violent
criminals um yeah it's it's part of the
reason the fewer negative consequences
there are for a certain Behavior the
more of that certain Behavior you will
get this is a basic fact of human
psychology any parent knows this to be
true if a child doesn't suffer any
negative consequences for bad behavior
he will continue behaving badly and if
the bad behavior is really really really
bad like carjacking then um then you're
going to get a lot of really really bad
behavior and
worse what about social media and rap
videos again yes no question all all
that plays a part no reasonable person
can deny that as for rap videos it's not
just that the kids are making their own
videos and and and and uh uh you know
making fun of their rival gangs and all
that kind of stuff it's also rap music
in general has obviously for decades now
been one of the drivers of violent crime
in our cities the fact that there are
people who will still deny this
self-evident Common Sense fact is absurd
though not shocking given that people
deny all kinds of self-evident Common
Sense facts these days but the reality
is that a
child who grows up from the moment of
birth listening to music that explicitly
glorifies and encourages violence and
criminality will be more likely to
engage in that behavior than he would
have if he hadn't grown up listening to
it and again like the fact that anyone
would still deny
this is is ridiculous we are human
beings we are persuaded and moved by Art
and by messaging in the media we consume
the entire adver iing industry hundreds
of billions of dollars is built on this
fact that you can encourage and promote
people to do things with just
messaging if you saturate the airwaves
with a message encouraging people to do
something more people will do it that
that is not a complicated
equation but all those factors are to
one degree or another Downstream they're
not the source they're important points
but they're not the most important they
are factors not the biggest Factor
why are so many black kids in DC killing
and robbing and committing all manner of
other violent crimes well before we talk
about social media or music videos or
even the criminal justice system we have
to talk about the fact that almost all
those kids are growing up in homes
without fathers nearly 80% of black
babies in DC are born to unwed mothers
which is 10% higher than the already
Skyhigh unwed birth rate for black
people Nationwide 80% which
leaves and you've heard this figure
before but think about what it means for
a second we usually don't trace this all
the way down so that leaves
20% of black kids with a father in the
home when they're born but keep in mind
that the black community also has by far
the highest divorce
rate okay
so a huge portion of the black kids
lucky enough to be born with a father in
the home will not have a father in the
home by the time they reach middle
school so so how many black kids in DC
or any other major city have a father in
the home for their entire
childhood well it's hard to say exactly
but that number is way less than
20% that much we can say for
sure the black child in a stable home
with married parents who stay married is
an anomaly is a rare exception to the
rule and that's the problem every other
problem is rooted in that one problem
you could go you could and probably
should ignore every other factor and
just focus on this one for now because
it's it's like the whole story why do
black kids end up committing so much
crime why do they end up dead or in jail
or in gangs or all of the above how do
you explain the black poverty rate black
unemployment so on and so on well the
black nuclear
family basically doesn't exist um that
that's how black kids are not growing up
in stable homes with mothers and fathers
almost none of them are at this point um
especially in in in the
cities and that's it I mean that's all
you need to know it's like it's it's
almost ridiculous to talk about anything
else when you've got that factor hanging
there right in front of you and yet this
one major underlying factor is the one
factor that is almost never mentioned in
any article lamenting or analyzing crime
and violence in the black community
they'll talk about criminal justice and
social media and music videos and
systemic racism and policing and
literally every single thing besides
this one thing that is without a doubt
the main thing your community has no
chance of success is doomed to misery
and failure and disaster and poverty and
Chaos if you do not keep your families
together and if you abandon the family
almost entirely if you become the first
demographic of people in human history
to essentially eradicate the nuclear
family completely then there is no
hope like nothing else will matter
nothing will help no improvements can be
made like we might as well just give up
and stop trying if you given up on the
family then then it's over there's
nothing like it's okay well that's it
that's it nothing else we can do so this
is the thing we should be talking about
when it comes to the pl to the black
community it's really the only thing we
need to talk
about or at least we shouldn't talk
about anything else until we have talked
about
that and that is why the people who wish
to continue ignoring this issue the main
issue the whole issue they are the ones
who are today canceled hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there